[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life we're
going to help you win with your money we
want you to win in your work we want you
to win in your relationships and we're
here to coach you encourage you along
the way the phone number is
8825 5225 8255 225 joining me today is
Rachel Cruz the incomparable the
graceful Rachel Cruz and she's our money
expert all the adjectives I kept it I
kept it simple you I don't want to get
too long in the list and make it look
like flattery and I'm Ken Coleman I'm
going to help you in the areas of work
how about more income that bigger shovel
to get through the baby steps faster I
want to help you there so we're going to
work together to help you Phoenix
Arizona is where we go Brandon is
joining us there Brandon how can we
help hey guys thank you for taking my
call I really appreciate it um I just
found the baby steps and the Ramsey
Solutions about two months ago um and I
have to say y'all have been a blessing
I've been listening to you guys on my
podcast while I side hustle for Uber W
uh and then also um reading Rachel's
book know yourself know your money and I
read the baby step millionaire book by
Dave in like a day wow that's awesome
you're binging it
all I'm I'm going all in it's long
overdue what's driving I love the
intensity but what's driving
it um yeah so I just um retired as a
major league baseball player after nine
Seasons professionally two in the major
leagues and I've also gone through some
hardships uh just in terms of a
relationship I had an engagement fail
back in
2021 um and then I also so had basically
my career just got derailed by injuries
the past few years sorry about that what
position did you play I'm a I was a
pitcher and I had three elbow surgeries
two Tommy Johns and owner collateral
ligament yeah so um basically I'm
transitioning um I'm I'm going to church
I'm Tiding for the first time ever in my
life which is CRA I'm was kind of
ashamed of that just given the amount of
money I made um as a professional
athlete but the that's the reason I'm
calling I know I'm long-winded but how
do you how does someone like myself
who's transitioning um into a new career
path to deal with financial mistakes in
my past and letting go of that shame and
guilt that I feel um and then also too
I've got a kind of a I'm in a little bit
of a budget situation that I could
really use some advice on all right so
real quick I want Rachel to dive into
this but have so do you have any money
at all because as a pitcher you probably
did well yeah well that's the thing is
like I made I out of the draft uh I was
given $300,000 signing bonus and
obviously after taxes that's a lot less
turned into
185,000 and I was drafted in
2016 um and I unfortunately for me I
didn't have parents they they are still
in the rat race they are still in debt
and they didn't really they're kind of
in terms of Rachel's book kind of the
type of parents that they didn't talk
about money all I really saw as a kid
was there was never enough let me ask
you this really quick did you sign a
contract or was that the only money your
initial contract yeah yeah so what kind
of money do you have right now okay
sorry um have 28 $28,000 in my Roth IRA
I have
$50,000 in individual brokerage account
um and then I have about
$45,000 in the MLB 401k plan MH uh and
then in terms of like checking I've got
about $2,000 there and then I'm working
on rebuilding my emergency fund um
unfortunately I've only got about baby
baby step one of a thousand bucks so I'm
bab are you just ubering is that the
only income you're bringing in now no so
I actually just got a job I won't say
the organization but I accepted a
coaching position uh for a major league
team in the minor leagues when will you
start yeah so I'm on first paycheck
comes in December 15th but unfortunately
it's a drastic difference in salary and
earnings compared to you make as a as a
minor league coach 40 yeah entry level
uh development coach I'll make 40 40,000
this year but they pay for my housing um
during the season so really like it's
yeah do you have any
debt yeah so right now um like I said I
dove in with you guys um I have I kind
of was keeping up with the Joneses
throughout my career like I said and uh
I have a a mesla model y that has a
outstanding balance of 42,000 okay I'm
currently listing that on Facebook
Marketplace and auto trader trying to
sell it y um so I'm I'm underwater there
because the value is only about 37 38
okay um and then uh I have a house which
is this is the biggest thing why I'm
calling um the house
uh was built in 2021 with $60,000 and
earnest money down after my engagement
failed I went to the Builder and asked
for the earnest money back they said no
so I had no choice but to move in um and
the mortgage is
$3,760 a month uh three and a half%
interest rate okay and then utilities is
usually
about uh the total cost is that all um
is that all your debt is the car in the
house car in car in the house and I have
like $2,000 in credit cards but I pay my
credit cards off every month Euro I've
never been late with the payment so
you've never been late but you have
$2,000 on it so you're gon to be paying
it in full at the end of
December yeah exactly I but but your
mortgage is too much is that what you're
getting at too exactly so like I'm in a
situation where it wasn't much when I
was a player sure yeah yeah and your
life has changed so living situation
will probably change too um have you
where will you go for well I guess you
don't want to say the city which is
totally fine yeah so what I would do
Brandon honestly if I were you number
one you asked about the shame and the
guilt earlier in the show here's the
hard thing about money is I could tell
you right now Brandon like I'm a mom and
I'm killing it as a mom this season of
life and but you don't I don't have a
number to that Ken could be like my
husband game is out the roof I'm the
best husband ever in the world there's
no number to that not saying that what's
sad is like what's sad is that at the is
at our money and what's hard is it has a
number there's a number that follow us
follows us around so as much as which is
very true that you're present and your
future Brandon can be 100% different you
the way you're looking at money and even
the stuff you're diving into
content-wise is going to help that
mindset shift the the thing that sucks
is like your numbers follow you right
and I think that it's that reminder not
for it to be shameful but to say hey I
don't ever want to go back there again
and so let me just encourage you Brandon
you're doing all the right things you're
selling the car you've got a new job
coming up uh you know you I I would I
would get rid of I would get rid of the
credit card I'd go all the way in on
this plan and just see i' sell the house
if you're moving somewhere else for this
organization I would because you're
going to be I mean right training I
don't know much about baseball but like
you're going to not be G you're going to
be gone a lot of the a lot of the Season
anyways so Brandon I would rent
somewhere I would rent a cheap bed one
bedroom somewhere you're going to be
living somewhere else for months out of
the year that they're going to be paying
for which is amazing so take advantage
of that and yeah I would I would sell
this house again this house was a dream
when your life looked different you were
a baseball player there was a girl in
the picture and your life doesn't look
that way and so as Dr John delone talks
about what's our reality what what what
is the reality and grieve what has been
lost because that is sad the career
change and a relationship change but
where you are now you have to focus on
this reality and this reality is that
this house it's too much for you it's
too much and it's become a burden so I'd
sell it yeah I absolutely agree and hey
uh your re starting you've been through
so many injuries you can do this this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based Health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
merry Christmas everybody from the
Ramsey Show it's that time of year I'm
like why haven't I said that happy I
know someone said it earlier on the show
um in the week when I was hosting and
they said they answered the phone merry
Christmas and I was like thank you yeah
the uh the raspy voice you've come to
know and love is Rachel Cruz we're not
sure what's going on she's working on it
she's got the loses working during the
break she's not sick no fever no no no
mask no she's doing great but you may
not recognize her voice but that's
Rachel and I feel like I'm a little
raspy so we don't know what's going on
but I'm Ken Coleman she's Rachel Cruz
this is the Ry show we're here to help
you win we had a call earlier this week
I think I was on with John and we were
talking about um someone wanted to cash
out their 529 that their grandmother
gave them oh okay uh but she wasn't
doing for school purposes and so we were
I was telling her not to cash out her
529 because You' be hit with income tax
10% penalty and I was like but you can
roll it over to a Roth IRA yeah uh cuz
it's been open for more than 15 years
and she was like what I didn't know that
was possible and I was like it it is
possible the B administ I got so excited
wow and my voice just cracked went out
gone and who and I told winon that night
who knew I was so excited about W 529s
going over to Roth IRA don't get too
excitable on the calls today cuz I feel
like your voice is working hard here so
uh here we go time for question of the
day brought to brought to you by our
great friends at neighborly Ramsey Show
question of the day of course always
brought to you by neighborly at the hub
for Home Services soon you're going to
have a lot of family over that's going
to make some people start to daydrink uh
but you probably won't have a lot of
help preparing for them or cleaning up
afterward you need Molly Maids go to
neighbor.com Ramy to find and schedule a
local owned Molly M by the way who
doesn't enjoy Molly mate you know I
think you'd be hard pressed to find
somebody today's question comes from
Michaela in New Jersey my husband and I
don't agree with no kid I got you my
husband and I don't agree on money I'm
currently pregnant and I want to be a
stay-at-home wife with our son and my
husband wants me to be out in the work
force ouch we can't come to agreement
and I need to know what I should do wow
okay glad no it's okay I'm glad you're
here on this one because this is this is
not a work question this is a marriage
question yes you know disguised as a
work question um so they don't agree on
money Rachel now she's prar right and
naturally wants to be a stay-at-home
wife but the husband is probably
freaking out I'm speaking on behalf of
all men we start to get controlling cuz
we really want to provide and he's
nervous about the money they already
don't agree about money we don't know
why but we've already got tension there
and now she's like I want to come home
and be with the baby and he's like no
and she's saying we can't come to
agreement what should we do yeah and
that's one of the problems again that we
see a lot when you don't agree on money
with your spouse it's usually not always
just about the money it's usually
because there's a value system
difference right and that's like the
core right it's not just oh credit card
not you start to you start to really dig
into these issues and you realize well
we have different values and it's coming
out as money issues
and that's what I'm what I'm interested
in this is I'm like there's probably a
values difference and I have it's funny
I have different friends in our lives
and some of the guys will say no my wife
is she's so smart she's capable she used
to work and bring in great money she can
and if the kids are in school all day
why doesn't she and then I have other
friends that are on the other side where
they're like no I'd rather her be home
because everything's taken care of at
home I can go make the like it's just so
funny to hear these two different sides
I always lean the first way you do I'm
being honest I'm going to be transparent
yeah that with Stacy you're like yeah
well Stacy's got a master's degree she's
made six figures before and she's doing
some part-time stuff now but we got
three teenagers it's expensive got to
buy two cars my default is always that
way and I'm always the guy cuz she'll
bring up well there's so much going on
and and I and I agree she is the CEO
sure sure okay but I go I'll help with
laundry like yeah I'll tag team that
stuff so that we can I don't there's
first of all dinner's never on the table
anyway God love you Stacy that's just
not How We Roll I'm okay with that
totally it's not a problem you know that
I'm not a caveman you know what I mean
or not out of the 1950s you know sitcom
uh but I I understand that I tend to go
that way too cuz I'm always thinking
let's max out our possibilities right
right and that comes from and the reason
I'm owning this is because I believe it
comes from my own scarcity think yes yes
what you totally do you agree yeah I
could totally see that and that's my
thing too is or the the value of not
being home full-time right I'm not
saying that you feel that was Stacy but
some people could say well that value is
unquestioned yeah right right I know
that's not you I know that's not you
yeah yeah yeah no I know but you're
right you're making a very good point
but I'm just wondering about Michaela
and her husband like if his value is
like no let's it is a scarcity mentality
possibly like what you were saying Ken
and let's bring in as much as we
possibly can cuz why not and hers is no
I want to pull back and be with the kids
so again for me what do you do how do
you get on the same page with that I'd
get some counseling and get to the heart
of where we disagree on money and to
your point why we disagree on money when
we get to the bottom of that y these
other decisions take care of themselves
yes yes exactly so it's really tough I
hate to hear that especially with a baby
on the way oh I know oh those motherly
instincts kicking triple 8825 5225 Kyle
is joining us now in Orlando Florida
Kyle how can we
help hey how you guys doing uh K Rachel
um love the show been listening for the
last couple months and uh two weeks ago
Dr Maloney said something that kind of
like triggered me it's been making me
think for the last two weeks it's been
trying to call in um I got an
inheritance from my father passing away
um I'm 27 he passed away when I was 20
uh so kind of saved that money my
grandmother passed away last year so got
inheritance from her as well and kind of
been accumulating this money
um I bought a house and I still have in
my bank account 990,000 cash liquid in
my high yield savings account and
125,000 in my brokerage account that me
and my girlfriend we do discuss going on
trips and going away and what what to
spend money on and what what things that
we need and what we uh can kind of hold
on for and I realized something that
Dave Maloney said that I'm almost like
afraid to spend money I have like a
decent amount of a nest egg over 200,000
and own a house can make the payments
and I'm almost like nervous spending
money and if even if it's like a two2 or
three th000 trip I'm like well how am I
gonna pay for this even though I'm
sitting here with a decent amount so I
wanted to call in um kind of get some
insight on like how do you kind of deal
with those thoughts Kyle are you on a
monthly
budget I am yeah so everything's paid
for mortgage is, 1500 um I do use credit
I know it's a big thing no I mean like I
mean I mean like a a budget meaning you
have your income for the month all of
your expenses from cable subscriptions
Insurance uh food restaurants groceries
you have it all listed out before the
month begins you know exactly what
you're going to spend money on on every
single category usually the answer is no
I'm very I'm very impressed if that is
true you really are on that detailed of
a budget every month what if I
interviewed people that know you would
they say you're tight tight food tends
to move around that one tends to move
around the gas and the food
but I kind but definely like the main
you want get
like good Kyle Kyle real quick are you a
tight wad would people say you're tight
you're uptight about money super Frugal
yes okay the reason I'm asking that
Rachel I think you wrote a book called
know yourself know your money and I
think it's really wise I it's got to be
from his past yes yeah I mean your
childhood can dictate a lot of this of
why how did you grow up Kyle with
money um so I grew up with divorced
parents um so my dad was an ex cop so he
was based on a pension so he did have a
very strict budget yeah um and I think I
got a lot of that from him um just kind
of knowing where every dollar is going
to go yeah um going up so uh Cal do you
have our every dollar app by
chance no I haven't used the every
dollar app I have like a spreadsh okay
um if you hold on the line Austin's
going to pick up because I want to give
you every dollar premium which will
connect to your bank and this is a
budgeting app so what I'm why I'm saying
that Kyle is because you with money you
always want to be doing three things
giving saving and spending all three
things and when one of those is
deficient you don't get the full freedom
of what money has and one of yours which
is spending not mine yours is is
deficient Kyle and so what a what a a
detailed budget like every dollar I want
you to do it it's going to help give you
permission to spend and Kyle I want you
to save every month towards a $3,000
vacation and when the money hits when
you plan it and you have that $3,000 go
on the vacation you almost have to force
yourself vac to spend but a but a budget
will give you the guardrails and the
guidance where it's not questioning oh
gosh is this okay it's permission it's
telling you it is okay so hold on the
line every dollar premium for you Kyle
thanks for the call Kyle this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right
[Music]
back
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drap and
shutters to motorized Shades they make
it easy and affordable to upgrade your
entire home and their team is ready to
help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of customer window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me in studio
this hour and we're here for you we want
to help you win with your money we want
you to help you win we want to help you
rather win in your professional life as
well as in your relationship life and
those three areas are always tied
together we want to help you win in all
those areas if you're not winning in one
of them it's going to affect the other
so we're here to take your calls we'
love to coach you and cheer you on
Triple Eight 8255 2258 825 5225 okay
Baltimore Maryland is where we're going
next and that's Britney Britney how can
we
help hi hi Ken hi Rachel um thanks for
taking the call um Rachel I hope you
feel better dear oh thank you so much
Britney of course um so I honestly just
me a quite a little bit of insight here
um I am trying to figure out ways to
either make more Mone money and save
more money um I barely make $330,000 a
year and after pretty much all of my
bills I have about 10 bucks left of my
name what are you doing what's your job
I I am a medical secretary for a
hospital okay and uh let me ask you this
what is just I mean in your head right
now top of the Mind here what's up the
ladder look like for you if I could just
magically wave the pencil around and we
bumped you up based on some skill some
experience what would that look like and
then what would the financial payoff be
what would the new salary
be well targeted right now at least a
good maybe $770,000 I'm not too greedy
I'm honestly just want to feel like I'm
not drowning um I actually took out a
loan against my uh 403b to take some it
uh software testing classes okay um and
I'm actually finishing those up this
month um but still you know have to put
myself out there and look for a job
which could also take months as well
well hold on a second so uh the mindset
there has to be you're already
identifying companies and positions that
this certification will prepare you for
in other words qualify you for and
you're starting to make connections now
so you have to have the mindset that I'm
shaking the tree to see what
opportunities could be there and maybe
waiting on me does this does this
program have a placement uh program with
it where they help you get placed they
they do not they kind of just basically
help with your resume and Linkedin
profile um in which I am currently in
the internship but haven't finished it
yet although I have already started
putting my resume out there just to kind
of get the ball rolling what technology
work will you be qualified to do day one
is it programming is it is it code it is
actually software testing quality
assurance engineer okay and is that
where you said a minute ago I didn't
understand you and that's my fault you
were talking about a $70,000 salary is
that what you've identified as as a
potential option coming out of
this yes okay great so I want to turn
you over to Rachel on the budgeting side
of things because I don't want you to
wait okay to start getting your money
and by the way if you can work two or
three extra jobs right now for some
additional income that's going to help
what Rachel's going to coach you through
I just want to push you into that you
need to take the bull by the horns here
and get after it so I want you connect
I'm going to give you a book called The
Proximity principle okay that's my gift
when we're done here so that you're
connecting with people and it's going to
walk you through tactically and
practically how you begin to make
connections so that opportunities come
in your way because that's going to be
huge for you but income alone isn't
going to fix this problem Rachel no it's
it's definitely going to have to be so
much of a of a mindset shift Britney for
you um because even talking to you are
so you're so kind and like sweet but
there's a there's a part though that I'm
like yes as as Ken was saying grab the
bull by the horns like there's kind of
that aggression too that I want in you
that I'm sure is there what's your just
um I'm curious your your family Dynamic
are you married do you have kids I am
single no children in a one bedroomroom
apartment um and honestly I was thinking
about um moving in with my dad for maybe
like few months or a year just to kind
of save up some money um because like I
said barely made 30,000 and like yeah
how old are you 34 34 okay um and what's
your what's your debt what's your car
payment credit cards all of that um so
um I have about 4,500 in credit cards um
like I said I took out a Lo for my
403d um which was only I'm maybe at like
2100 right now but um probably the
second part of my advice meeting is that
I actually did something um really now
that I know is stupid um last year I was
going through a hard time and actually
kind of short long story short got taken
advantage of by a friend um and it's
something I know I shouldn't have done I
put my name down so that she could get
an apartment but I basically wanted her
an apartment in my name um because she
was having trouble with her own kids and
I was going through my own heartbreaks
and things like that and was feeling
really vulnerable um but long story
short she did not pay any of the rent
and wed up about yeah it wacked up about
$11,000 in dead in my name now so okay
uh and is the $111,000 that's that's
separate than the 4,500 credit card and
2100 403 correct okay perfect what how
much you how much do you owe on your
car I don't my car is paid off okay
that's great great news um okay so
here's here's the good
news the good news is Britney there's a
lot of upside to your income there right
now in this time between now with this
career you have and hopefully going
forward um which you're getting your
training and all of that which is great
between now and then if I were you
Britney I would you could move in with
your dad if you want 's a part of me
that I'm like you're an adult you can do
this right you can do this and there's a
sense of dignity there that I think is
really um which I think is really
important but I I think it's going to be
uncom an uncomfortable season meaning
the amount of hours that I would
encourage you to work Britney because
there's not much expenses to cut you're
living on
30,000 and so I like there's not there's
nothing to really cut there right so the
income side though to me is huge I'm
like even if you took four nights a week
Britney and said I'm going to drive Uber
you know three of those nights I'm going
to do instacart two like like you you do
some extra side hustle work which
actually can bring in a good bit I mean
some people are seeing $2 $3,000 on side
hustles so even bringing that stuff in
you're going to be able to pay I would I
would pay off your debt smallest to
largest so i' would pay off that 403b
loan ASAP uh get that out of the way and
then the $4,500 credit card debt I would
cut up your credit cards today I would
force yourself to live on what you can
and and we talk about the four walls
that are really important Britney your
food your shelter utilities and
transportation and I said I know I said
earlier as as I was talking with you
that I wouldn't want to move in with
your dad but listen if there's a season
that you're like for six months for rent
all of it like if I can cut some stuff
because even my four walls are tight you
know maybe that is an option what is
your
rent U my rent is $1,300 could you get
out of that how quickly is that a month
to month or you have to finish out a
lease I have to finish at leas it is up
in June the 1st of June okay so six more
months yeah I if that's an I'm with
Rachel on this one I'm going to say six
months from now if you get after it uh I
don't think you're going to have to move
I I I think this is about you going what
must be true for me make an additional
three to 500 bucks a week now that's if
you break it down like that it's not as
intimidating okay but if you go okay
what do I have to do and if I get at
like you can knock that $2,100 uh loan
out very quickly next on the list is the
$4,500 in credit cards and honestly the
stupid tax of the $11,000 debt that's
the biggest one you can actually do this
you've doubled your income over the next
six months to eight months on the
technology side of things you start
networking and connecting like your life
depends on it you're going to get a good
job and and now it's about managing uh
the mistakes that you've made and go you
know what I'm not an idiot I've made
I've made a mistake or two or three and
Bry any savings you have too I would
throw at this debt to get this moving I
think for you having some confidence and
some quick wins for you Britney is so
it's possible and it's needed for you
because once you're out of this debt and
you have a fully funded emergency fund
you're a whole new person like there's a
level of confidence that you're going to
have in yourself knowing that you can do
this hard stuff and you're going to
learn from those mistakes not going back
into credit card debt not being taken
advantage of from a quote unquote friend
that screwed you over like all of these
things Britney are lessons to learn and
do something different the next time
which you will so these numbers are
great I think working extra is going to
be your best bet yeah absolutely this is
the Ramy show we'll be right
[Music]
back hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague and
friend Rachel Cruz Merry Christmas to
you hope you are um not stressing out
over all the things uh around Christmas
and it's become about getting getting
getting and then the stresses around
giving the thing that everybody wants to
get just remember around this time that
it is ultimately about giving and and
make sure that you don't lose yourself
in the in the in the music or the moment
as uh Eminem said once famously did you
like how I just transition right into a
little wrap from just Eminem CH Coleman
an Eminem he would say Lose Yourself you
know say go the mile Don't Lose Yourself
nice good reference there good reference
um slim Slim Shady the I used to be
called Slim Shady no I didn't uh but
smoking cigarettes and listening to
Eminem apparently I know I know we we're
going off the going off the range um
little fun thing um let's I want to find
out uh next segment uh what your one
your favorite Christmas movies is and
maybe we'll we'll do an object lesson
out of it okay I'm I'm I'm taking over I
did on the last on the Rachel Cruz show
the Christmas episode that comes out we
did my top five favorite Christmas
movies and the money lessons to learn
from them oh now this is what I want to
do that's even better you took my
horrible idea and you went that's what I
want to review and you're going to love
them I can't actually it's going to be
really great so you're going to have to
hang around next next segment next hour
next hour so you go to you got to hang
around for that all right let's go to
Izzy by the way I always I think my
name's very boring James likes to have
fun with it with the puns like you were
very kaining he does those things but
what if my name was Izzy I think I would
be much cooler Izzy is cool and Izzy is
in Boston Izzy how can we help you hi
guys thank you for taking my call I love
your name can I tell you that love your
name thank you very much K I like yours
thank you I appreciate
so um my question is so I've obtained a
bachelor's degree by this past summer
and my next step is to try to get into
PA school and become an emergency
medicine pa um but what I would like
some advice with would be is it okay to
take out loans for PA school and if not
what advice do you have for me to pursue
this career path and take on as little
bit as I as possible okay so walk me
through what you think the path looks
like maybe the next couple steps or or
years and let's attach some money to
that meaning what it would cost for the
education necessary and then maybe what
you're making can you kind of fill me in
on that I think I can answer the
question a little better yeah of course
so right now I'm I'm on baby step two
and I have about $1400 in credit card
debt and in student loans I have about
$25,000 okay and that's it what yeah
that's it I I've paid off my car is paid
off I I don't I don't have any other
sort of debt okay great um but what the
ne yeah the next steps look like right
now I'm I'm searching for schools and
both within Massachusetts but also
outside and what will happen is is I
would start applying to programs in
April now the thing is is that most PA
programs do not allow you to work while
you're in school because it's such a
it's so rigorous um but also I'm in the
most competitive State and also one of
the most expensive programs is in in
Boston um but if I were to move out of
state I would have to take on you know
living expenses but right now I live
with with my mother and I only pay you
know the utility bills which is about
$500 to $600 a month so what would the
PA program cost you then in
Massachusetts in Massachusetts right now
the program that I'm looking at it
ranges from 115 to
$130,000 and what's a what's what's the
path what's the salary coming right out
of PA school coming right out of PA
School especially if I um I want to work
in emergency medicine which is what I do
right now I'm a nursing assistant in the
emergency room okay so fresh out of PA
school I would probably and if I move to
mass you know the salary varies from
where you live in state but I think I'd
want to work in Mass um it would be
about5 to
$120,000 okay and what are you making
right now in that role right now that's
that's that's a thing so in the
emergency room you do not get paid much
as a nursing assistant um I make about
$15 an hour base pay um so this past
summer what I've done I love Landscaping
so what I did is I opened up my little
gig and um I was able to make pretty
good money I'd pay off a good chunk of
my debt um but I can't do that in the
winter so I'll I'll continue working all
right let me ask you this I love your
hustle by the way love it all right I
have one more question and I'm sure
Rachel and I are going to weigh in here
um y based on your current degree that
you just got what's the best paying gig
you can get with that biology
degree yeah so I had a feeling that you
guys would ask me this question the the
thing is is that I haven't thought much
after I obtained my biology degree
because my plan was always to go
straight to school sure and then my
cousin
you know he got me into listening to you
guys and you know I just I've always
seen my mother kind of live paycheck to
paycheck and I just I don't want that
and so we don't want that either yeah so
you got to answer the question for me
thought Beyond so you haven't looked you
haven't really look yeah which is fair
totally fair toally you're what 20 22
izy I'm I'm 24 24 okay here's what I
want you to think about Izzy I want you
to think about let's let's split the
difference between the 115 to 1 30 is
what it's going to cost you for a
student loan okay let's just say it's
120 for conversation I want you you
don't have to do it right now but I want
you to reflect sometime today on how
long it would take you to pay that back
and I want you to also think about if I
told you to pay cash which is what I
want you to do how long would it take
you to save up could you save up 30
grand a year well at 30 grand a year
it's four years to be able to pay cash
yes yes or cash flow slow your way
through it so the question is living
with your mom um you know the cash
option is best for you is you do not
want that stress because even at making
115 coming out of this degree after tax
I want you to run the numbers what is
your after tax situation and I want you
to do it's almost like a pre-budget uh
and I think you're going to go oh my
gosh I don't want to sign up for that
I'd rather be patient and could I save
30 grand a year okay which gets through
uh gets me to four years of C or can I
cash flow and if it's going to cost me x
amount per year I'd love to know what
that number is per year okay and then
can I live with my mom and I know PA
school is hard and they don't encourage
working but what is the other option
being miserable and being in debt Yeah
Izzy
I I don't know why it's like the people
pleas are in me sometimes that I'm
always like I know our advice is not
what you want to hear so I always
hesitate to be like I'm sorry is either
what what you're going to hear you're
like you're going to think oh my gosh
Izzy six months ago before her cousin
told her to listen to ramsy but I'm so
glad we got you because our advice is
going to be different because normal
normal would just say oh of course you
got to go into debt for PA school and of
course you need to go right now you just
finished your undergrad of course that's
the next step I mean it's exactly what
your mindset was and Izzy I can't tell
you how many calls we take on this show
of people that have debt of people that
took on this amount of debt and and the
stories of even you know they get
married they meet someone get married
have a baby something is wrong you know
they want to stay home because of I mean
like Health stuff I mean you life
happens and when you take on debt you're
taking on risk so what we want to do is
eliminate risk from your life because
that gives you peace and it actually
gives you money at the end of the day
and so the most peaceful wisest route
izy and this is what I would do if I
were you I would say hey I'm going to
put all this on pause for 3 years which
means you'll be 27 we talk to 35
year-olds that want to go back to school
right so I'm like you're early in the
game you have the time you have the time
and to say I'm going to go try to find
you're smart obviously so I'm going to
go try to find a job making 60 and I
don't and honestly I don't care what it
is it may not be in the medical fear
we're going to just go make it because
Izzy listen and if you stay with living
with your mom I'm okay with that because
you're going to pay off the 26 the
26,400 that you owe your credit card
debt and your student loans you can pay
that off in the first year keep working
that job for two years save and save and
save you'll have enough to cash flow
that first year of PA school do your
Landscaping stuff in the in the summer
you can make a killing on that and just
and and stockpile cash and when you go
through PA School you will be writing
checks when you get out of PA school
you're going to make $120,000 and it's
all yours Izzy and you're starting that
off at 27 years old it's unbelievable
unbelievable that's going to be the
wisest piece of Ral for you Izzy you're
awesome I'm so glad you called thank you
Izzy we believe in you this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your money life
your work life and your relationship
life the phone number to jump in on the
conversation is AAA 825
5225 8
825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality and I'm joined by my good
friend Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz
we're both a little raspy today we don't
know why we haven't been yelling at our
kids I promise but we've got the throat
coat going I know are you rest you're
not you don't think I am I'm about to
start coughing you're really struggling
I'm good so if if her voice falters I
just jump in until she's ready again
it's uh you know just how it works it's
just the weather it's the weather but
anyway we're excited to coach you up we
want to help you win jump in 888 825
5225 let's go to Mobile Alabama Chase is
joining us on the line Chase how can we
help well Dave uh it's a pleasure to
talk to you Ken I'm a big fan Rachel
thank you for taking my call you bet
thank you for calling what's going
on I uh I'm 25 and I'm trying to get
some advice on how I have a adult and
proper conversation with my parents
about their
financial uh situation I planned on
getting them Financial Peace University
for Christmas and was hoping that I was
able to talk them in into just checking
it out and giving it a shot I felt like
if they at least gave it a shot that
they would be hooked um but I wanted to
do this right with good intentions and
love and not make it feel like it was
just their kid trying to get involved in
their finances have you ever talked to
them about their finances
before it's a delicate topic me and my
dad talk about Fin quite a bit we get
along with it but my mom and my dad are
not on the same page um they haven't
been for a long time they have separate
finances separate bank
accounts um they keep everything
separate and the last I was kind of on
the fence to rather to do it or not and
last night they kind of got the news
that my sister's transmission on her car
is about to go out and they don't have
an emergency fund so it felt kind of bad
telling them that and seeing their faces
when they got that news
is your dad um is he more in line with
you on on what they should be
doing yeah he uh he is the one who
actually introduced me to y'all um when
I was a little bit younger uh as as Dave
would say he's he's davish he's done it
in the past but he never stuck to it and
and what's your mom's what's your mom's
likeo Chase your mom what's her status I
think she feels like it's a little
controlling and I I understood it when I
was a little younger cuz I was so
worried about you know what was you know
what was going to be today I wasn't
worried about next year five years down
the line 10 years down the line yeah and
I'm definitely more coming around to
that but I feel like she's more worried
about tomorrow okay and the end of the
week yeah here's the big problem the
problem is they both have different
accounts and different philosophies so
you gifting them FPU I mean I think it's
a great thing but they they've got some
some serious serious marital issues
around money that that I'm not sure that
you can stick your nose in and even if
you could or did it would make a
difference soel what do you think I
here's what I would say if you were my
friend and we were hanging out I would
say one thing I've learned in life and I
can save you thousands of dollars of
therapy for this one you can't control
people you can't and as much as you
which is what I've done of like a
certain person in my life I can conjure
up some conversation and I pray the
whole way there and I think this is
going to be the thing I'm going to say
the thing and the light bulb's going to
go off and they're going to turn and
it's going to be heroic and great and I
don't need the credit because their life
is good like like I I conjure up this
whole thing that if I just say the right
thing and have the right conversation I
can help them see X Y and Z and Chase
I've had to let that go completely
because is your heart there to help them
absolutely but you can't control what
they're going to do and here's another
thing Chase they're not asking they're
not coming to Chase and saying gosh
Chase I feel like you're just not
stressed with money what are you doing
will you show us so what you're doing is
a little bit which I'm fine with you
gifting them FPU I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing but I think your
expectations have to be very low and the
role that you play Chase is a hey I'm
giving you this gift because it's helped
me I'm talking as you chase and I've
loved it and if you guys want to try it
out awesome here it is and you wipe off
your hand and you walk away
because you can't that's not the role
that you play in life for them and and I
hate to say it I feel like that sounds
like oh we're going to just turn our
backs or something and it's not that
it's just the reality of the
relationship so that's what I would say
Chase go ahead and gift them FPU I think
that's a really kind thing and you can
say from your experience how it's helped
you but besides that there's nothing
that you're going to say or I wouldn't
put that pressure on you that this thing
you're going to say is going to change
them and or they're not asking for your
advice and they're they're grown-ups and
now I would say this and I think
Rachel's absolutely right she is 100%
right but I would have at least one
manto man with my dad because you guys
seem to be in alignment he it's like he
agrees with it philosophically his dad
knows though he does but i' say I know
but I take one shot If This Were Me and
my dad I would go Dad I want to support
you I can't do anything about this
you are going to have to lead mom you
are going to have to do something about
this and I hate that you're in this
situation I'll support you however but
I'm GNA tell you dad I think this has
gone on too long you guys need to get on
the same page and I would challenge my
dad but just once just once I'd go Dad
this is on you man I know but he's not
asking like that's my thing well they
talk about money I think they are
talking about yeah but in conversations
how is he coming to you with money Chase
he well I mean he's you know we're very
into each other's you know he's just
making sure that I'm okay with you know
my finances and I'm more worried about
him I think he wants them he wants them
to be on the same page that's what I'm
hearing he's made that very clear and
then that's up to him there's been some
there's just some Dee rooted like trust
issues when they had their own their own
bank account and that is not yeah and I
would say Chase that's just not your
Arena to play in and here's another
thing I and I would not triangle and
it's sounding like a triangle situation
with your dad and you triangl against
your mom and you don't want to be in
that Dynamic either so oh Chase I your
heart is so good and your intentions are
so good and I get it and like Ken said
maybe there's one good run at it of just
like Dad I can't sleep at night unless I
say this for my own conscious like here
it is and then Chase I wouldn't and if
your dad brings up conversations with
your mom to you I would draw a boundary
there too and say Dad not not my problem
I'm sorry I'm not the one to talk to you
about and I get yall are talking money
and all of that but I would just be
really careful I just think as grown
children those boundar I just think that
those conversations are really important
because it can get tangled really quick
and I don't want responsibility put on
you Chaser you're feeling a level of
responsibility that is not yours to
carry so I don't know if I'm being too
harsh on that but or too strict but no I
I think there's a lot of wisdom there
and I I don't know if the ManUp
conversation is a good idea now that
you've made me you made me almost
rethink it but what what I mean is I
here's what I think's happening I think
his dad's coming to him and he's kind of
treating him like the counselor and he
needs to go to a real counselor he
coming to the son cuz he's like well my
son did this and I don't have the a
natural connection there yeah yeah and I
think that's I think his dad's terrified
of his mom that oh boy probably good
truth but uh you know I don't know it's
tough good heart chase you got a good
heart yeah you're a good man this is the
ramsy
show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz and
we're here for you this hour the phone
number to jump in is 88255 225 taking
your questions about money about your
work and income I need to get more
income side hustle starting something
can I make a move during the baby steps
anything related to that we would love
to help youle 882
55225 so it is the season I don't know
if anybody talks that way anymore but
it's certainly the season it is the
season okay I was afraid you're going to
roll your eyes and go there's old man
Ken again just the tollfree call uh but
uh I that's right never again by the way
people were on Instagram going yeah Ken
uh I'll call the toll-free number from
my home phone I was like okay all right
Point made all right but I love
Christmas and as I look about the uh
Lobby here at Ramy Solutions we've got
it all decorated I got in my house I
love the Christmas music we need so you
have a fun little Christmas money we're
going to play we just made this up on
the spot I love this go ahead uh I'm
going to say a money lesson explain a
money lesson and Ken is going to try to
guess the Christmas movie that that
money lesson is from and all of you on
YouTube play along I'm going to number
them one through six okay and try to put
your guesses in as well before before
okay so here we go hold I got to get
focused these are going to be kind of
short so hope they're going to be good
here we go number one don't spend your
work Christmas bonus on a pool until you
actually have the money Christmas
Vacation the greatest Christmas movie of
all time ding ding ding ding
ding um number two okay don't steal a
credit card and try to check into a
hotel Home Alone ding ding ding
ding what's that uh lost in New York
Home Alone 2 you know what James got me
on a technicality I missed that
one okay he's a stickler folks he's a
stickler number three this may be a
little tough um I'm trying to like just
paint the lesson is even if there if
there is no Christmas presents a town
can come together and still have
happiness and
joy boy I'm going to go with my instinct
here if I'm wrong James is waiting I'm
going to say It's a Wonderful Life no
that's a that's a good one to have money
lesson though How the Grinch Christmas
how the good job James see I'll be
honest with you don't know that I've
seen that movie folks okay the next one
uh people would would debate if it is a
Christmas movie I'm going to say it is I
think you've given me the clue yeah yeah
that's a clue I guess yeah um if you
switch houses and do VRBO make sure it's
what you expect do your
research come on Kenneth think I'm I'm
gonna give Ken about this may be Stacy
Coleman's favorite romantic movie I'm
going to go with the holiday yeah ding
ding ding ding ding wow I can't believe
my wife is going to be very proud of me
folks well done um okay number five this
one's gonna be kind of hard to explain
let me see if I can do it um if there's
a sign in the mall that says for someone
special and you buy it they may not want
or need the
gift does James have it okay James has
it hold on do you really I don't have
it's kind of br oh look our audience
even knows she knows she knows is that
is that elf is it elf I was going to say
that or Paul Blart mop I wasn't sure
what it was going to be well done well
done thank you for the clue from the AUD
number six I would not categorize as a
family friendly movie oh boy wouldn't
let my kids watch this one it's one of
Winston I's favorites though we think
it's so funny um if you lie to here's
the lesson don't lie to your family
about not visiting them on vacation
saying that you're going to go on
vacation this is going to be a hot take
and unpopular take but it has now become
my favorite Christmas movie it has gone
above National L's Christmas Vacation it
is Four Christmases four Christmas I am
a Vince Von fan K and I I got to do a
sound effect I I'm probably going to get
in trouble for this but I got to do
it that's where they're going to
inoculate the kids in Burma and he makes
up Burmese in the bedroom while they're
packing it cracks me up funniest movie
that and one last one okay swaddle that
baby oh the Christmas service is just
too much and then Graham Graham but I'm
going to stop there Graham Graham Betty
White no that's not Betty White no it's
not Betty White oh my gosh you're right
sorry yeah no it's true though you but
you know they make a very good point you
can't spell lies without family I mean
for Christmases if you've not seen it
adults I think it is an instant classic
is so funny we watch but it's a
wonderful life is one of my favorite
movies and Mr Bailey I didn't even I
didn't think of that one to do a money
but that's a great money and I'll throw
it well but see this is a part of the
newest uh episode of the Rachel Cruz
show so we're having a little fun with
this but you actually do a a deep dive
on this yes yes yeah we can I mention a
movie for next year to go along with it
wonderful life Miracle on 34th Street
yes I haven't seen that in years I know
and these are Classics would you do the
Black and White Version the original the
original yeah because it's really sweet
there's a great great character lessons
in James you have and I can I also throw
another movie out for next year yes I
think it's a Christmas movie I'm pretty
sure the and the audience you you jumped
ahead would it kill you to wait would it
kill you to not interrupt me I was
setting it up I think die hard's a
Christmas movie that's what I think you
think it is Austin says yes James says
the collective Booth says yes dudes cuz
you're all dudes all the women no it
happened at Christmas it was a Christmas
party it's not a Christmas it's like the
holiday people would argue is it a
Christmas movie or not all right there
you go couple good things lots of
lessons to learn God It's a Wonderful
Life I need now let me turn this to real
money stuff for people yes what do you
know from the data and you've been
coaching people for a long time what are
the biggest causes of Christmas mistakes
money mistakes oh what would you say
Obviously overspending yeah for sure 25%
of Americans are still paying for Last
Christmas what yep an article came out
yep last week from wallet hub
uh yeah quarter of Americans I mean it's
unbelievable that they're still do you
think that we as Americans spend too
much per capit what I mean by that is
per household um like within reason your
budget's different than everybody else
my bud people are overspending so here's
so I did an interview today you would
love this Ken they're they're WR they're
writing an article comparing 1950s
Christmas yeah to today and what do they
see and well they were interviewing me
about today so I didn't get all the
historical facts but you're a tro I feel
like you could go back in those days but
but we were talking about and like the
expectation of Lifestyle in general yeah
from for sure the 50s even the 80s it's
average square foot of a home you know
the cars I mean everything about it just
our natural Baseline of lifestyle is
high and that bleeds over for sure into
the Christmas season and so it is it's
this expectation and it's the buy and I
think too cuz this gets me it's the
stuff you don't plan right like we do a
budget and we plan out hey here's how
here's how much we're going to spend on
Christmas and then you know a you know a
party comes up this happened to me last
week and it's a bunch of girls I know
and it's a favorite things party I'm
like well I want to go but you got to
bring two items I mean they're 20 bucks
each so it's like 40 bucks that's 40
bucks that you know we didn't plan
exactly I had I had to run out the other
night for Josie she's like Dad tomorrow
I've got my secret Santa at school and I
got to get this this this and this and
I'm going what are you what are we
talking about yeah get her an apple
that's what they did in the 50s I'm
kidding I didn't say that I wanted to I
wanted to I remember you probably don't
remember this but some of you are old
enough to remember when the Tickle Me
Elmo first came out oh I do remember it
yes people were punching each other do
you remember those wrestling like
jumping off the third you know like a
WWE move over this gift that your kid
doesn't even know about I mean it's wild
it I mean that's what's crazy and I do
miss a little bit of that hectic
shopping I feel like there were always
new stories the Furby was it one year
like I feel like we had all these like
toys and you'd watch the news and watch
all these crazy people I don't know go
crazy over a toy so yeah I do think it's
I think it's not being able to plan well
because you're trying to do everything
and when stuff comes up you just add on
and or not having the margin But
continuing to live Y how you want to
live and there's a point that we have to
be grown-ups to say I just can't do that
you know and it's hard to say no to
ourselves but oh my goodness I I think
and here's the other thing look
this this whole holiday is supposed to
be about what you give not what you get
and if we're giving different things you
know like we we can fix the whole thing
by changing everything to all you can
buy is one ugly Christmas sweater for
everybody you know and then it becomes
more about the fun of just that right
but we've made it about stuff and I
don't know that we're ever going to get
it back but hang in there please don't
make any crazy money decisions it's
going to be okay and don't be like those
people that Rachel's talking about that
are still paying for last year's
Christmas oh they kiss heartburn Cousin
Eddie where are the Tums where's the
eggnog fell in a well eyes went crossed
kicked by a go back go there it is oh
I'd hold off on that she's got a little
lip fungus we haven't identified yet
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz and
we're here to help you win in your money
and in your work Life by the way if
you're enjoying the show no matter how
long you've been listed to the show one
of the things that we would love for you
to do if we're adding value to you in
any way we'd love for you to share the
show uh subscribe leave a great review
share it with a friend that all helps us
get out there you know how those
algorithms work I don't but uh they're
out there and so all of that helps us
get in front of people who may be
struggling certainly this time of year
as we head into the Christmas season a
little bit strapped financially maybe
heading into the new year and wanting to
uh Break Free of all that debt and uh
get a good start we'd love to help so uh
please let people know
8825 5225 let's stay right here in our
uh the back of the uh Woods if you will
I don't even know what I'm saying uh in
our neck of the woods there it is I
don't Nashville Nashville Tennessee is
where Kate joins us Kate how can we
help hi
Kate hello how are you you're on with
Ken and Rachel what's going
on um I was recommended to check out the
or to call on to the radio show to get
some advice about uh my husband and my
financial
situation um it's more on my end um I
you know moved out on my own two years
ago we just got married a couple months
ago and I've just been struggling to
find consistent work um that you know
that pays enough to the point where I've
been on and off unemployed over the past
n months and obviously unemployment
brings on debt and I'm trying to figure
out how to work with that while still
being unemployed okay so what kind of
debt have you
accumulated um I have some credit card
um and just some medical and other
General debt okay and what kind of work
would you love to be doing if we could
just make it happen for you today what
what would that be and what would that
income look like realistically
um oh ideally I would say farming um
realistically
I went through a course for data
analytics almost four years ago and have
not been able to find a job in that yet
okay can I can I ask a question what's
causing all the unemployment for you you
said I'm having a hard time keeping a
job um some of it has been living on my
own due to the rising costs I've had to
look for other jobs just to stay afloat
um I recently was diagnosed with a
thyroid illness and and realize that's
part of what's maybe be unemployed is I
have difficulty getting out of bed in
the morning and showing up to work okay
now you said that you've kind of moved
on from thing to thing is that what I
took from that answer because you were
trying to make more money so your job
hopping yes but you're not hopping from
something to something you're just
leaving something then trying to find
something else sounds like well I have
been moving from one job to the other
when I've been able to okay um but
sometimes I've been let go due to the
illness and had to find a job from being
unemployed okay so let's just hone in
what we need to do right now to get some
income for you now that you've got the
thyroid uh condition uh diagnosed and
I'm assuming you're getting some
Doctor's Care on this and do can we
presume that you're going to be getting
better and that energy issue is going to
be taking care of itself is that
true that's what I'm hoping for okay so
we don't know so the issue is would you
be better served doing uh maybe a remote
job work from home where it's that it's
kind of that is the thing they are
expecting is that a better fit for
you uh that's what I've been trying to
find for almost four years now well
sweetheart let me just tell you
something and I want to say this as kind
as I can uh you're in Nashville and this
one of the hottest job markets in the
country when you look at states and
their states economies and we look at
the general economy there are a lot of
jobs out there and and if you can't find
something
um there is something going on with the
way you're looking or the way that you
are actually applying and getting into
the situation because you should be able
to find something right now with all the
online freelance work that's out there
where you can make even being a personal
assistant um a virtual assistant Kate
yeah you know you could pick up two two
clients and do that what's your husband
doing you said you've been married a few
months what's his
status um he is a full-time student he's
about to start his final semester um to
graduate with a Bachelor's in Business
Administration so he's not
working um he works part-time but very
limited part-time because he is a senior
so you guys are broke and barely making
it
by
basically
okay yeah Kate I think the the the part
of the formula that I think just has to
be the one part you really focus on is
this income side Kate and like Ken said
there's a lot of jobs that you can do um
from home it's either going to have to
be that or your husband is going to have
to say hey I can't go to school right
now cuz my family doesn't have money my
wife is sick and can't work and I can't
I I don't care if it's my I'm a senior I
have to pay my light bill and my rent
and my mortgage you know what I mean
like there's a level of adult choices
here that are not fun but that have to
happen to survive in our world today and
I'm not talking about the luxuries of
life I'm talking about okay you guys got
to pay bills I mean to keep the lights
on and the and the rent paid and so he
may have to stop school I mean he may
have to pause Kate like that's how see
that's how like urgent I want you guys
to feel unless you can find something
which I have confidence you can but it's
that urgency you looking for four years
and him staying in school full-time
working part-time you that just that
doesn't that doesn't happen you can't do
that does that make
sense I don't know if I to clarify with
the four years um I was looking for my
specific
ideal role okay gotta which is what
years I have been working since then but
it's been the lower income unable to get
decent savings kind of jobs okay well
but wait a second you can okay so the
ideal job is in farming and I get that
and I think when you're getting healthy
we want to get you on a path to that but
Rachel's right your hubs has got to be
working two jobs he doesn't have a
thyroid condition and the degree can we
can get back to that degree it will be
there he doesn't even need the degree
honestly a Business Degree doesn't
guarantee anything I I don't I don't
want to kind of pour salt in a wound
here but Rachel's 100% correct he's
working two jobs maybe three jobs to get
you guys in the income where it needs to
be to pay off the debt
weekend he's working Nots St and I will
tell you you need to be looking at
customer service roles until this
thyroid thing gets under control I think
it's very hard for you to go to a
Walmart or a Target or someplace like
that when you've got this physical
condition that is is obviously sapping
your energy and and Untold other issues
here's the point you can be working
online
tutoring um Customer Center customer
care those jobs are inut data inut I
mean like anything yes anything Kate
even if you're bringing in 25,000 a year
that's something do you know what I'm
saying like there there needs to be it's
what the two of you can do not this is
not on you yeah this is not on you fully
yeah so he need so yeah you both I think
how old are you guys
I'm 25 and he's 23 okay yeah so yeah
this is um by the way Kate one of the
questions you need to ask is will you
help me it's a question that we don't
want to ask right you know people you
guys you're young you've come from a
network a connection to families in the
Nashville area you've just got to go hey
I this is where I'm at I've got a
thyroid condition it's now diagnosed I'm
getting treatment but this is where we
are hubs is in school we need to make
money we'll do anything and you've got
to start putting the word out do you
understand what I'm saying this is not
applying online and just hoping your
resume makes it through the The Matrix
this is you talking to people posting on
social media go hey I'm looking for X
amount of hours this is what I raise
your hand out there you got to raise
your hand is a great way of saying that
Kate you got to get after it which takes
humility right I'm like to your point we
hate doing it yeah but you guys are in
that situation um where you need it
because how much is your rent a month
Kate um it's 700 so it's not that much
okay yeah it's a lot when you're broke
and you guys aren't bringing anything in
and then you got food I mean yeah I mean
it's all of this so yeah any amount of
money Kate to get you guys in a stable
place but that's probably going to mean
him make working Saturdays and Sundays
and nights I'm like that's and and and
and and bartend be a waiter like find
like the places that you make some good
money too I hope your husband watches
this have you watch to hey hubs listen
to me you can come to my neighborhood in
Franklin and and say I'll put your
lights up your Christmas lights outdoor
for 200 bucks I'll pay you so fast your
head will spin I don't want to do it
that's right but there's there's
something to be done right now that's
right that's right so this is we are
urgent because we must provide and then
it'll cycle out thank you Kate this is
the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win in your life your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
colan Rachel Cruz joins me and we're in
the Christmas spirit so Merry Christmas
uh we we had fun that was a little fun
exercise the game that we played oh
earlier yes our Christmas movie trivia
Christmas movie trivia TW you and James
yeah all spot on yeah absolutely uh all
right back to the phones we go Brian is
now joining us in Danbury Connecticut
Brian how can we help
hey all uh thanks for taking the call um
so my uh family is expanding thankfully
uh uh we are uh in the process uh we
purchased a new home we're in the
process of of moving to that home um
we're in the fortunate situation where
we didn't have to sell our existing home
in order to to purchase the new home
okay and so now we're we're sort of left
with a question of what to do you know
whether we should sell it whether we
should rent it out um we did buy the
home
preco um and we bought in an area where
uh a lot of uh New Yorkers have moved
too so uh uh our property value um has
has in increased thankfully because of
that so yeah that's that's sort of where
we are we're just uh wondering what to
do with the home okay how much do you
owe on that home the old
home um so the mortgage we have on the
home outstanding is about 560 560 and
how much would it sell
for um we've been told it could sell
around 1.2 1.3 amazing okay and how much
is new house how much of a mortgage did
you take out for that new house the
mortgage is
680 okay so if my math serves me
correctly Brian you could sell your
house your old house current house and
pay off the new house
correct something like that that's
that's the dream now why are you
chuckling where did the chuckle come
from why why so I guess you know I guess
two things number one uh you know we we
are changing uh moving towns and we're
sort of uh there's a little bit of
emotional attachment I'll say to the to
the existing house um you know like
visions of moving back and and doing
something with a property or something
um but also just a question of what's
the right investment you know does it
does it make sense to hold on to it as a
rental uh or does it make sense to to
just sell it how far away are you moving
from
it it's about an hour it's you know not
too far how much do you guys make a year
Brian uh my wife and I are both are both
in Tech so uh we we gross around 340 a
year nice do you want to be longdistance
landlord because an hour is still like
an hour is just at the point of a pain
in the you know what and can I add this
Brian that and you guys said you have an
emotional attachment to the house some
family's going to move in there with a
dog and three kids SP and you're going
to be like speaking of EMS and you're
not going to want to move back into that
place I mean I mean honestly to move
back in after three or four other
families have lived there it
just the Romanticism of it leaves I love
this what's your favorite what's the
favorite part of the house what give us
an emotional
attachment it's it's I don't know how I
mean we're in the Christmas season the
best I can probably describe it is it's
just like a nice cozy house and a great
neighborhood you into the cold F like
it's just worth 1.3 million yeah there's
that I know I know the other bit I don't
know if it's helpful is our mortgage is
you know part of it I guess is we
because we bought
pre-o um and mortgage it mortgage rate
was like
3% um you know the the mortgage monthly
we're paying you know with insurance
taxes
hon that doesn't really Factor majorly
into my into my thought process because
for you guys do you have any other debt
do you owe stuff on your cars credit
cards no no no no okay
Brian listen here's where I here's where
I would say to keep it if you if you
called in Brian and you're like we're
making a million a year I'd say you know
what pay off your you guys live on
nothing pay off that house pay off the
other one keep it as a rental because
it's yours and you own it outright in
three years whatever whatever whatever
but this keeps you I mean 560,000 on one
680 on the other it's keeping you guys
in debt and so when it when debt comes
into
play there's a lot of this that's just
it it I don't know it just adds on it to
me more stress and the idea of oh it's
just passive income the renters will pay
they'll pay the more like all of that
that people believe about rentals is
just not true there's more of a headache
now if it's all paid for and you can
take on the risk of something that's
something else all right now I just had
a thought Rachel Y and I don't think
this changes anything but I got to ask
Brian I mean yeah danburry Connecticut
pretty historic places I recall I've
never been there but pretty historic I'm
guessing pretty high income okay what
would the nice New England towns that
sort of yeah yeah yeah I actually want
to go sometime but how what would you
say the rent is the market do you know
what the market rent is what you could
get for your
house um we've been told because the
market is so constricted right now that
we could get around 5500 6,000 a month
and what's it what's the mortgage on it
like 3,300 a month that's with
taxes it's not changing my opinion I
just wonder if it changes my co-host
opinion on that that's interesting
you're doubling up now now you still got
the pain and it's an hour away and okay
I have another question you said the
hope is we return When would that be
when would you return if that was even
an option I mean we talk I know it'd be
like you know five 10 year time okay
that that sort of thing all right I just
wanted to
mind honestly Brian it doesn't and I
know people are going to go on YouTube
like Rachel the y'all are you're crazy
because here's what I think Brian and
I'm usually a glass half full kind of
person but I'm just thinking oh my gosh
what if in 18 months 24 months who like
what if something happens to the market
what if one of you loses your job what
like like this thing that is supposed to
be so great and in a perfect world it's
great where Brian in a perfect world you
could sell it Bank
$220,000 that's what I'm doing every day
of the week by the way and putting that
half that you know maxing out retirement
putting some of that in a Vanguard
account letting it grow going on
vacation on just the interest I mean
like you know what I'm saying like your
life I agree with you it's all of it I
would sell it and I get that it's a
really sentiment like I get that there
make some videos before you leave yeah
and can I tell you this Brian have y'all
moved into the new house
yet uh not not yet no and is it an
upgrade of a house would you say like
it's nicer and it's it's a little nicer
it's importantly just more space because
the family's growing so that's the
principal reason why we're okay so do
you like love the new house though are
you excited about
it yeah no it's a it's a great I mean
wife and I are sort of the people that
are uh really sticklers about about
things and this this house check and I'm
only saying that Brian cuz my husband
and I when we built and moved in in 19
2019 our house we had only lived in one
other house it had been about 11 years I
brought all three kids home from the
hospital in this house it's big it's
right when Winston and I moved as a
married couple we had spent a decade of
you know K and all of it and I cried and
I took pictures of every bed I mean all
of it and I just told wi I was like I'm
just I'm so S I am so I'm so sad but yet
we're building this home that we're so
excited about but I'm so sad I'm so sad
Brian can I tell you this this is not an
exaggeration we moved in two to three
days later I had to go back to the house
because we forgot something in the
garage I had to pick up and I walked in
the kitchen and I was like I I want to
go back to my new house
I I flipped a switch and and again and
and you may not but I'm telling you when
you make the change yeah the Glamour and
the and I understand the sentimental
Factor but it it seems just to I don't
know for me it it always be special but
it's not a reason I would keep it for
$560,000 you're so right I'm with Rachel
take the cash keep the memories and go
and live run off into the sunset with
$220,000 in cash after a paid for home
Brian and then think about this y'all's
whole income is yours huge income and
$33,000 rent not even going to be a like
or $6,000 you know what I'm saying like
there's just so much now that brand new
house or that new house for you guys is
a massive investment that's paid for in
Connecticut yeah aay I like it at
Connecticut real estate by the way oh I
can't only imagine you ever been to
Connecticut she doesn't know no I was
going to say Boston but that's
Massachusetts yeah okay I'll show her
the map don't go anywhere more coming
this is the rsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsay show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically ly winning with your money
winning in your work and winning in your
relationships the phone number to jump
in we'd love to coach you today is 88255
8255 225 Rachel Cruz joins me I'm Ken
Coleman and we are thrilled to be here
to coach you guide you we want you to
win so let's get to the phones Susie is
up in Seattle Washington one of my
favorite cities uh you were just out
there recently I was yes little te Swift
a little T Swift action this summer
fantastic love Seattle that's where
Susie is Susie how can we
help um well first of all thank you Ken
and Rachel for taking my call Ken you're
the perfect guy for this question um
after 33 years uh the corporate
headquarters where I um work is moving
uh out of state and um my question is
about how I go through this
transitionary process where they are you
know we we kind of have an end date
that's vague and and and how I go about
interviewing and what do I share with my
current boss about what I'm doing I mean
obviously I I'm not going to stay they
know that um and and it's just a a weird
kind of ethical thing I have going on in
my heart yeah well you're a very very
very upstanding high integrity person
because of even asking this question but
I would tell you this may shock you I
wouldn't tell them anything now what I
mean by that is I tell people all the
time don't cheat on your current job so
if you're going for job interviews and
you got personal time or your lunch hour
you use that you know what I mean don't
you know you're not going on job
interviews when you're supposed to be in
the office so I want to be very clear
about that but they know you're leaving
you already told us that they know why
you're leaving company's relocating and
my guess is you're a you're a an
employee with high stand is that true
with your
leader correct yeah I'm I'm I'm just a
person that kind of wears my emotions on
my sleeve I'm the cheerleader and for
the the couple of us that are looking
for other jobs I'm I'm kind of like
trying to encourage them at the same
time and so do all that it's a weird
line no it's I mean I understand what
you're saying but I'm trying to tell you
there is no line here it's not unethical
for you to look for a new job when
they've told you your job is essentially
in
and they know you're not going to
relocate so it would be in my mind the
issue is not is it ethical it would be
nonsensical for you not to apply for a
job and to go do interviews does that
make
sense yes all right then so you don't
have to tell them anything and don't lie
I mean right like if they ask you point
blank be honest of course but but but my
point is is that if you're going to do a
job interview and you got a lunch hour
then then instead of taking your normal
lunch hour then then then go do your job
interview and you take that hour and
you're a good Steward of what you're
supposed to be doing now you're not
doing anything wrong now to Rachel's
point if they go hey are you looking for
jobs go yeah which by the way they're
probably going to ask you because they
know you're not staying with them anyway
so none of this is a secret therefore
you don't have to act secretive but you
also don't have to walk around going hey
I uh interviewed the other day like
let's just go about our business like
it'd be like it be like me telling
Rachel like hey you know she knows I
probably have to go to the doctor every
once in a while but I don't go hey I
went to the doctor today I got a case of
gout she doesn't care she doesn't want
to know I don't have a case of gout but
just saying I even if I know what that
is it's an
overshare you know what I mean it's like
you don't need to share this because
you're not doing anything wrong does
that make
sense yes the other Nuance here is that
they're having a very hard time finding
people in the new state and they have in
in the other departments that have
already transitioned they offer them to
stay longer and and up until this last
month I've been pretty clear that I was
willing to stay longer but my heart has
kind of changed because um partly
because of your show I am uh encouraged
about the job market I know there is
something better for me out there and
I'm excited about that and because of
the rampy plan I H I have total
Financial Peace I am not concerned at
all about that and I'm ready to move on
and so I'm also kind of worried about
that transition when they ask me to say
if I if I don't or if I um well here's a
deal you're right though it's on paper
that they letting me go on this that's
right and here's the deal you're such a
nice person you're probably a bit of a
people pleaser and you're probably
wrestling with some guilt but You' have
not done anything wrong see we use the
word guilt we apply guilt to something
that is that is I've done wrong you know
and and so you've done anything wrong
and I think you're just very open and
clear and if they ask you to stay a
little longer you go well I don't think
I'm going to and that doesn't make you a
bad person and it doesn't make you
ungrateful I think that's what you're
wrestling with yeah and Susie they're
you know even when you said oh my gosh
they're having a hard time finding
people in this other state if they have
trouble what that's not your
responsibility you know what I mean like
there's a point that they've made this
decision as a company and now that
decision is not sitting well with you
because of you're not going to move and
so naturally your heart has moved on do
you know like that's it's a reasonable
line of thinking you're not like out of
the blue this crazy person I mean it it
that all makes sense so just just know
that too yeah Susie you're you're a
great lady and there's great things
ahead and I would be moving forward on
everything that you want in the next
season of your life no guilt thank you
so much yeah you bet appreciate that
what a sweet lady I love that yeah so
and just as a little tack on to what she
said she said because the Ramsey plan
I'm able to do this and that's a
beautiful thing can that we talk about a
lot when you put yourself in a position
financially you guys and the Ramsey plan
is you're out of debt you have money
saved in the bank you're living
intentionally you have options so like
even if su's company came in and said
you're laid off Susie probably would say
okay cuz I don't have debt and I have 3
to 6 months of expenses in the bank and
no I'll just look for a new job that's
really sad I've been with them for a
long time but I'm going to just you know
even if this decision was forced upon
her it still has a level of Peace
because things are taken care of and so
there's wisdom in that you guys but even
on the front end she can proactively now
say I don't want to go with where my job
is going and she's thinking about
something else now think about something
else and and even if you don't have
something for a month or two like it's
okay you know so it's a very good point
the Financial Freedom that Susie has
gives her the professional Freedom right
now when this change has been forced on
her and now she's like I I I kind of
want to do something else it it kind of
reminds me of that scene from Jerry
Maguire have you seen it yes you know he
finally leaves yes and he's thinking
he's got the world you know and and he's
in the car and he just rolls the windows
down and he's singing Tom petties I'm
free and he's letting it go and that's a
guy you know in that situation is going
look I I'm doing my thing I'm doing what
I want to what I want to do and in this
case Susie I think that might be the
play might be a little chilly in Seattle
but maybe we uh crank up to Tom Petty on
the drive home tonight and just enjoy
she's financially free which means she's
free to do what she wants and by the way
that's what everybody's longing for is
freedom yep that autonomy over your life
where you have a say I know George
Campell and I were talking this morning
on my show and um we were filming a
segment for his new book Breaking Free
from broke if you have not pre-ordered
that make sure to pre-order you get some
free goodies and stuff with the
pre-order so check that out at ramsy
solutions.com store but we're talking
about how you know you go through high
school and college and then you're out
on your own out of your parents telling
you what to do and then you all of a
sudden look in a system that's telling
you what to do the financial system or
you're looking to the government
whatever telling you what and it's and
I'm telling you it's like when you break
free from all of those quote unquote
systems you have the ability to have a
sale over your life in so many ways in
your career and in youry money so that
freedom is is massive tell you what I am
fighting the freedom to do is to sing
that last that that big that big refrain
but I think James is going to write me
up for it so I'm going to just do it
during the commercial just for the just
for the cuz I'm free there it is that's
all I got this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by by Rachel Cruz and
we are here for you to talk to you about
your money your work and your
relationships the phone number is 8825
5225 tri8 825 5225 Victoria is joining
us now in Philadelphia Victoria how can
we
help hi um I've just had I guess a
question um and just wanted your opinion
on me and my husband we just bought a
home okay tell us about it so my husband
so my husband was in the military the
last five here so we lived on a military
base and um I own my own um Paar studio
so with living with no expenses with the
military we were able to save up quite a
lot of money so when we moved back home
our intent was to buy a home and not to
rent so we lived with my parents for
just a month before we found um a town
home in the area that we wanted to be in
um we kind of went into it knowing like
it wouldn't be our forever home it's
just a small tube bed little town home
um but we didn't want to rent and not be
able to save up another significant
amount of money as our down payment um
so we went through with buying it and
now in my head I'm like will we ever be
able to get out of it it's not a forever
home how long should we stay in it so
not that I have like regret of buying it
but sometimes I wonder should we have
just waited to buy a forever home or was
this a good move all right let's see
what the the details give us here so how
much did you uh put down how much do you
have left on the
mortgage um so the it started or it
started at
385 um and we put 10% down and we also
bought out the PMI okay so how much I
think we have about about 360 I believe
358 something like that and how long ago
was this that you bought it oh uh
exactly a year ago in November of 22
okay okay and besides it just not
knowing it's not your forever home
because forever home's Victoria honestly
yeah it's kind of a
romantizm but that rarely happens I mean
some people do they buy their first home
and they stay in it forever and ever but
most people move two or three times
right houses in their lifetime um so for
you guys I understand yeah not wanting
to rent especially when you have the
money saved so is the mortgage how much
is the mortgage compared to your income
right now does it feel like a
lot um I feel like it felt like a lot
coming from you know not having any
bills so our payment is 2700 a month we
have a 6.9% interest rate so it's
definitely not low um Al together with
like all of our bills we probably end up
paying maybe $3,300 a month um my
husband alone brings in just about 7500
himself per month and then um I'm a I'm
a business bus owner so it's now that
it's it's a my first year owning my hair
business in this state so I bring up I
bring in about 12 Grand a month but you
know I have to pay 12 Grand a month yeah
but she's pay what's your take home yeah
that's well that's the thing it's
different every month but I would say
maybe around seven um which is still
really good but you guys have a 14 you
got $14,000 yeah your your income yeah
you're got you're fine your ratio of
mortgage to your to your income is great
um yeah y'all are fine Victoria I think
I would you're probably having a little
buyer remorse because it's probably just
sticker shock it's one of the largest
purchases probably the largest purchase
you guys have ever made um I think you
were in a great I mean you guys had
prime position to buy do you guys have
Consumer
Debt um you mean any other debt yes any
other debt besides this mortgage um just
our two car payments which I have I
think 12,000 on mine and he has I think
his is in the 20s um so it's not too
they're not too bad how much are the car
payments a month um mine's 325 and his
is 400 good grief I'd be more nervous
about that I know $700 going to car
payments do you guys have any money
saved uh yeah I have about a 100 Grand
saved and he has a just around 30
what what what what is going on here hey
Victoria you guys are great I would I
would pay off your cars today and know
more of his savings and my savings you
guys together have 130,00 y'all need to
start looking at this as a as a unit
right that you guys together have
$130,000 put it in the same account the
same high yield savings you guys this is
a together conversation you and your
husband are having uh or living out is
yeah together this is what you guys have
you guys have
$130,000 pay off your cars today
Victoria you have a great savings you're
in a you're in a be beond perfect
position you're great can I ask you
Victoria have you seen another house and
you know your income and you've been
really disciplined to save that kind of
money is this because you see something
else that you want you're like d d it I
got my money wrapped up in this other
thing is that what's going on yeah
that's exactly what it is so I'm 20 me
and my husband are both 23 so the fact
that we were able to save so much I feel
like at a somewhat young age I'm like
did I not waste my money on this house I
waited no no okay so now all right let
me be big brother for a minute okay let
me tell you what you've done you've been
really really smart except for these car
payments and Rachel's right cut a check
for $32,000 today if I wrote it down
right 20 and 12 and you guys still have
right at 100,000 in savings high yield
savings account you guys are making
money Handover fist you just gave
yourself a $700 plus month raise cuz the
car payments are gone you know what I
would do if I were you and I W let
Rachel correct me here cuz she's a
little sister and believe me she'll
correct me I would take the the $700 a
month that you've been in car payments
and I'd put that towards the next house
after you've got your emergency fund
you're investing 15% all of that should
be you walk in the baby STS but i' take
that 700 and i' go that's we're going to
save up and we get through year number
two of having that home so we don't take
a capital gains hit and then if you want
to sell yeah and you got a down payment
that you saved up for with the rules
that we give Rachel I'd like to see them
stay in the townhouse two or three more
years don't be in a rush you've got a
great asset yes exactly yeah I would be
okay with that Victoria or putting 700
towards the house so you have built an
equity and you have built an equity so
you're building Equity so when you guys
save you have more equity in the house
to use right for the next house margin
they got margin to do both my point is
you're fine Victor I at 14,000 take home
and you said your your bills are we're
going to call I think you said 3,300 or
something just around that my goodness
yeah you could be doing the baby steps
paying towards that plus saving a down
payment you did not do some no you did
not do something wasteful this is it you
you you did it you're doing great yep
you guys have a nice does help you does
that help you like okay we're okay
making me feel better yes it does make
me feel much better do you guys um do
you see your F like do you guys want
kids soon do you see that you want to
move areas is there any of that that's
kind of playing in okay it's just it's
just you just really freaking out that
you own something kind of yeah like have
enough space for us too it's just like a
want to have more space than should we
have waited to get what we want listen
let me tell you and Rachel's great at
this you said it I'm going to remind you
what's going on you know you can afford
something bigger and better and and you
didn't get it and you're going You're
trying to play armchair quarterback and
go back and go oh but you can't do that
you guys are making more money now and
all this is is ah I'd like this and on
paper financially what we're making we
could make it we could we could get that
house and that's all you're dealing with
that's it that's it you didn't make a
bad move though and you can upgrade down
the line yeah be patient is wait a
couple years and you want yeah yeah wait
a couple
years up if you want but but you're good
and this would be a good season too
Victoria of practicing a level of
contentment right because I think there
is something in the sense that we what
we even though we can do it financially
do we need it and there's a little bit
of that discipline in that and I think
that's what's hard but we always like
warn people when they have money saved
and they go to the mortgage broker the
mortgage broker is automatically be like
no but look at the house you could get
you could get this much of a of a
mortgage and you're like nope I'm doing
this I'm doing this so I think there's a
level of practice of just hey you guys
are really blessed you've worked really
hard you've been really smart you're
good you don't you don't need more space
even though mathematically you could you
don't need it so Victoria I would take
this season and I would have sweet
memories and a space that maybe feels a
little tight to you guys but it's a but
it's a good season of life and then when
you want to UPG grade later down the L
you can but you don't need to what do
you call these hands on Instagram oh oh
this means all done with babies s what
what's a little praise hands Emoji
praise hands that's what I'm doing you
can't see Victoria I had to have Rachel
help me she's better at the whole social
than I am that's what I'm doing right
now you guys are crushing it so happy
for you praise hands that's what that's
called that's what I call it praise
hands Emoji oh I did it wrong cuz I
started doing thought you're doing this
this is what you do beon sign language
for all done this is the r show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me we're here
to answer your questions about your
money and your work and your
relationship triple
8825 5225 8825 5225 Portland Oregon is
where we go next Carson is there Carson
how can we
help hi um I'm looking to start a Fab
Shop with a friend of mine and I'm just
curious if that is something that I
would have to take a commercial loan out
for is that even smart no um I'm also no
I'm also uh trying to go into a welding
program right and that will also require
me to take out student loans okay whoa
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
you know I want you to keep going but I
I want to understand this how much is
the welding program going to cost
$28,000 and that is how long how long of
before 10 month program how
much uh $28,000 for a 10mth program 10
months okay and um what is the different
what are you going to do with that is
that going to help you in the Fab the
the Fab shop where you're Fab all that
fabricating or is this something
separate um no it will help me as then
because when we start the fabrication
process I'm going to be running all of
the business but it's just going to be
me and my buddy doing most of the
welding and I don't want him to be alone
doing all the welding
okay is there another option than a
$28,000 welding
program well I've kind of panicked when
I heard that and I called you guys and I
called my parents and um my dad has owns
a business he owns a body shop and has
welders on his payroll and he was
looking at buying me a welder actually a
TIG welder for Christmas and just buying
the material myself and I I'm just
thinking about it and and I've talked it
over with my friend who's the welder and
according to him I can learn how to weld
all on my own you can and I don't need
piece of paper you don't need it at
allson so Carson thank you for playing I
was walking you right into that uh
because welding does not require any
kind of Licensing welding requires
experience you're surrounded by welders
uh Carson please please please please do
not take that program do not take it you
don't need it number one number two you
can't afford it and your dad is in an
industry that's you could sit down with
any of those guys and watch and learn
and let me also say this just business
101 Carson you get this business up and
running and you need a second pair of
hands if you're not at that skill level
yet you can hire that out there are
plenty of welders out there and you
build that into the cost of doing the
work so you having to take this course
is is it's not a requirement and I don't
want you to take the loan out now let's
talk about the business business itself
what do you think it's going to cost
real Capital to actually start this
fabrication
business $300,000 what's the 300,000 go
for what talk me through that leasing
leasing the building out for a period of
time however that may be um the welders
in particular the welding tools T
welding the me welders all of that the
gas um that's going to cost around
$3,000 for the gas it's going to cost
around 10 grand for all the welders and
it's going to
cost well the welder salaries that's
that's the thing cuz there's per DM and
then there's you know how much you're
actually getting per hour and I'm
thinking well I would want somebody
starting out at at least 25 cuz I want
somebody of skill all right and her DM
that well that's $100 a day or $75 $50 a
day depending on the level of skill so
how old are you Carson I have to call
I'm 19 years old Carson this is great so
I'm I'm going to challenge those numbers
but I like that you're already able to
Rattle off those answers but you're 19
my advice to you is go work for a
fabricator get the welding skill by
getting paid to do it working with your
dad working with friends of your dad get
into this business but have somebody
else pay you you're 19 maybe you do it
for four or five years I'm not going to
hold you to that I don't want you I
don't want to hang that timeline on you
I'm giv you an example but let's just
say that you did it for 4 years that put
you at 23 and you've been making really
good money as a welder or in a
fabrication shop even if you're on the
business side because I hear more of a
business guy than a welder so if I go to
work for somebody who's winning in the
car fabrication space and all that and I
get a master's degree in real life
experience while I'm getting paid and
I'm putting money away and I'm I'm now
going to take that new welding skill and
I'm going to make an extra $50,000 a
year and four years I got 200 Grand I'm
trying to play this out for you that my
friend if in fact it's going to take you
300 Grand to eventually open up your own
business you are so young and so far
ahead of the game with your vision and
knowledge be patient because at 26 you
could start that business cash have zero
risk and be crushing and be a
multi-millionaire Carson the amount of
small business owners we talk to that
are paying for companies that have
closed eight years ago and they're still
paying off the loan
it's not good so remember this move at
the speed of cash it's going to be
slower it's not going to be as exciting
but you're not you're going to make way
less mistakes and different decisions
when you're using your money versus the
banks so no at please at
19 don't go take out a student loan for
$208,000 please don't go take out a
business loan with your friend for 100
grand don't do the 300,000 loan no no no
none of that I would not do any of that
yeah take your time you're very smart
you're you're going to start the stuff
is going to start to click and you're
going to start to understand oh my gosh
if I just stay in this and I'm patient
and it's going to go by so fast 3 years
it's like a blink I mean the stuff life
goes by so fast Carson take your time
and you're going to freaking kill it
you're going to do so well and and it's
going to be all yours it's going to be
all yours so do not take the risk of
taking out that debt go listen one last
thing on this to all young people like
this if you want to start a business in
a certain field when you're this young
go work for somebody who's crushing it
in the field the amount of knowledge and
wisdom you're going to get while getting
paid is enormously valuable and
sometimes you may get into the business
and be like oh is this what this is it's
not all it's cracked up to be it's not
what I was thinking people do that a lot
where they good point have this idea of
something and then you go get it and
you're like H what do you say Rachel can
we help Rebecca yeah we'll go quick
let's go Rebecca in Minneapolis how can
we
help hi um I'm just calling because I'm
going back to work um next week I just
had my third baby so maternity leave is
ending oh and daycare costs are going to
be starting um I already have one son in
daycare and we paid 225 a week for him
to be in there full-time and right now
with adding a baby we're going to be up
to 425 a week yeah which seems pretty
steep for our area
um I've kind of been looking around at
rates and just for an in home it seems
like a lot um we've been with her for 5
years and I just don't know if it's
worth bringing up you know a
conversation about like whoa what
happened or I mean pay living is crazy
yeah yeah I mean like why because I had
my daughter when my daughter and son
went I paid 360 for them to be there uh
for fulltime so it's jumped pretty
significantly inflation and I just don't
I don't know if it's worth the
conversation or is that just something
that we got to stuck up for two years um
I think it's always worth a conversation
I think um yeah I mean I think it's
totally fair to talk to her and just say
hey here's the numbers we had here's our
situation is there any way you could do
400 or 37 or 390 or you know what I mean
give her a price
that's fair because like you said her
rent on the place may have gone up I
mean there's there are these expenses I
would assume she's not just jacking the
rate Jack the rate she may be but
there's also a lot of cost that goes
into owning right a business and so I
would offer her another price and just
see if she takes it and if she doesn't
yeah you guys are either it's going to
be two years of dishing out 425 a week
for child care find other options if you
feel safe doing that and or one of you
guys wrestling with the idea of like
does one of you just stay home right I
mean there's a point where Child Care
can be it is it's so expensive it's so
frustrating it's so frustrating but it
can be so expensive that you have to
equate hey is this worth the tradeoff of
what I'm actually bringing home in my
other job and is it making sense
financially and for our family so that's
always a conversation but I would have a
conversation with her and and offer her
a different price and see if she takes
it yeah thank you for the call congrats
on the new little one I know and this is
a hard I know going back after third
it's a lot Rebecca so I feel you don't
move more of your calls coming up this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me this hour
the phone number is 8825
5225 our scripture of the day comes from
Galatians 6:10 so then as we have
opportunity let us do good to everyone
and especially to those who are of the
household of faith our quote
today comes from Theodore Roosevelt it
is hard to fail but it is worse never to
have tried to succeed always got a uh
that guy would have been a great locker
room speech guy you know would I'd love
to see him give a pregame talk we get
the president in here today he's gonna
fire you got the Army Navy game coming
this weekend I could see him giving a
talk there so there you go uh there's
your little known fact of the day nobody
cares about the Army Navy game uh coming
up this weekend this is a sad time for
me all college football is ceased I know
until we get to New Years yeah it's a
really tough time for me a few weeks be
thinking about me thoughts and prayers
for me on the weekend well I'm sorry
yeah thank you Mike is up in Cleveland
Ohio Mike how can we help yeah hi guys
nice to talk to you good to talk to you
so I had left a 10-year career in health
and fitness uh about two years ago
trying to get into like a new career
space um looking at like project
management or some sort of leadership
role uh at the hospital I'm currently at
and my current role it's combination of
a lot of different fields I'm in Virtual
Health coordinator and uh it's part it
customer service vender management
project management tech support um my
question is I have an upcoming surgery
in January where I'm going to be off for
about six to eight weeks and I'll have a
lot of free time I'm just wondering what
you would recommend I can do to ex
expand my skills my knowledge um and if
there's any courses or certifications
out there that I should be looking into
yeah so I love this question I would get
to the most practical things that will
help you get where you want to go so if
you want to get into project management
Andor leadership I would be focusing on
those two things so just off the top of
my head I'm going all right what
leadership podcast am I going to be
listening to the entree leadership
podcast a great podcast here from Ry
Solutions what leadership books I can
make recommendations on that but I'm
going to be really diving in I've got
this downtime so I'm going to be reading
I'm going to be listening I'm going to
be watching and and so I would start
there but my question is are you wanting
to move into project management and then
allow that to kind of set you up for
some leadership roles which way do you
really want to
go that's that's the part I'm still
navigating um and I'm doing that with
like my current um my current supervisor
he meets with me once a month to kind of
explore career options I was in
leadership in like the health and
fitness industry um and I like that part
um and now I'm in my current role I'm
doing a little bit of project management
um so at this point this is kind of
where I've just kind of started to get
my feet in the water and figure out more
clearly what I want well so for instance
we uh at Ramsey Solutions we did a i
partnered with our Ramsey education
department uh about a year and a half
ago we came out with a project
management course um and so taking a
course like that if you if you're not if
you haven't done anything more than just
kind of I stepped into I'm dabbling in
project management my current role a
project management certification would
be a great thing to do in that 6 to 8
week period um and again kick the tires
on what we've got I'll have Austin
connect you to to our team on that you
can see if you want to use that or not
but it's a it's a really good course but
absolutely I if if project management is
something you're interested in I would
do some research on several courses like
like you would a college course and go
do I really want to spend the money and
the time to take it and I think that's
the answer I'd talk to some more people
who are in project management this is
why I wrote the book The Proximity
principle is largely look if I want to
do something I want to get around people
that are doing it and and get an idea of
the good the bad the ugly and and so
before you make any of these decisions
on what to do let's do a little bit of
research and I think your heart's always
going to say you know it's either that X
from Family Feud the you know or the
ding ding ding and and looking into
something and and talking to people who
do it that's when the heart comes in and
goes oh H I don't actually want to do
that and you've been in leadership
before it was just a different industry
so if you loved leadership before my
guess is you're going to love it again
and if project management somehow gives
you a little bit more skill and
experience to expand your leadership
role and you like the idea of it then
I'd go with it but that's that's my
advice I want to keep it really simple
Rachel yeah and I think you know Ken's
advice of sitting down with people that
are doing it I think is one of the
smartest things because you can kind of
have this broad idea and talk to many
different people in different Lanes of
this and in different Industries and you
really will start tweet out my husband
Winston just did this uh a few months
ago and he was like it was so funny cuz
you kind of have one picture in your
head and then you kind of okay that was
that was good information from there
okay I got that that I mean probably
four or five different meals lunches and
then another opportunity pops up and
he's like oh now I really know that's
exactly what I want to do there because
of you know it's all of it so go and and
have lunch with people talk with them
and all these industries and people are
happy to share their experiences and
what they know the good the bad um but I
think that that's one of the best
resources you can do and and I think it
is so helpful just to weed down okay
this is it this is really what I what
I've realized I loved yeah absolutely so
Mike where you're standing right now I
mean what is that five seven 10 year not
holding you to this what would you like
to be doing yeah that's that's something
I've talked about with my my boss and
uh it it just coming from such a
different space it's it's hard but I I
know one of the pieces of the puzzle is
I the current hospital I'm at I would
love to stay there long term and then um
I I do want to get back into leadership
it's just I don't know um you know which
area of the hospital I would want to
fall into well then as Rachel just said
that's what you're starting to do you're
in you need to be setting up meetings
with people in all those different
Departments of the hospital whatever
that looks like and get an idea where
you want to land that's the good news
you're already in the door and and U and
then so if you want to be in the
leadership role I would just be using
that downtime to just fill yourself up
with knowledge but then get some real
wisdom like Rachel said from real people
who are leading in the hospital industry
and whatever that's like that's a very
nuanced World very different than
probably what you're used to but the
leadership side is still the same
nothing's going to change you care for
people you love coaching people you love
serving people you've got great
experience there all this other stuff is
now is just like what's that sandbox I
want to play in and I thought Rachel's
advice was great and uh by the way most
people are afraid to do that Rachel
they're afraid to just go hey can I take
you to lunch can I buy by the way
everybody loves to get a free lunch and
a free coffee and the only thing people
love more than a free lunch or a free
coffee is talking about themselves
you're G to say yes like I mean this is
a no-brainer hey uh hey Rob can I take
you out for lunch my treat I want to
pick your brain on what you think about
it doesn't even matter what you say
after that he's Rob's going to be like
yeah I'm in man absolutely give me a sub
and a Diet Coke and I'll give you what
you need a sub and a Diet Coke all of a
sudden we're at Subway and Rob is
dispensing WIS yeah yeah yeah yeah
better call there but isn't that true
though yes well and it's and it's having
the real life it's just like the the
young guy we talked to last segment
about the welding there is something
about just real life experience and I
think that's one thing you know I know
about the education system you have all
your your thoughts and stuff on and I'm
like and that is one missing piece it's
not the real world you can take as many
classes on something true but when
something is just in a formulaic way or
in your head what you've made it up to
be it may not all be accurate until
you're really in the nuts and bolts of
life and asking people's experiences and
understanding with the filter right that
they're bringing their own stuff to the
conversation so right it's but it's but
you're getting a picture of okay this is
kind of what this looks like
expectations uh and even I mean even for
him in a great way it's like that
specific hospital and you know you're
going to learn the culture of that place
you're you know I mean like there's a
lot of things you'll be able to pick up
nuances within that and within those
conversations with people that is very
helpful too uh to be on your side as you
start this leadership track so couple
little practical questions coming off
this call for a lot of you that are out
there wondering even on a side hustle do
I launch it let me give you a couple
quick questions based on what Rachel and
I have been talking about do I want to
do it does my heart get excited about
the idea of doing I want to now you got
to follow up with can I do it do I have
the core talent that with training and
experience that I could pull it off and
then how right so how meaning what's the
best way by the way there's always
multiple paths up a mountain yep and so
that everything we've just described is
going to answer those three questions
and if you do that guess what happens
you've got yourself a really good plan
that's not very risky because you know
what you're getting into it isn't just
I'm walking blind trying to hope that
works out so there you go Rachel Cruz
absolutely fun show today thank you my
friend uh by the way she was telling me
she's on the Instagram and she's putting
out these these great things of great
advice all the time so check her out on
the gram at Rachel Cruz she's dropping
the wisdom bobbs go check her out I'm a
Ken Coleman this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
oh